yang speaks is sponsored by expressvpn
protect your online privacy today at
expressvpn.com
[Applause]
yang
i really suggest for people to try to
embrace a growth
mindset about communication it's a skill
you can improve and as you do so you'll
reap the rewards of doing that even just
a sense of command of
wow i actually am in command of some of
these things
as a parent we know growth mindset is
the key to life really
right you know if if your kid's like oh
i'm bad at that being like well
you know you can get better because you
can get better just about anything if
you decide to put some time and energy
into it
[Music]
hey it is my pleasure to welcome to yang
speaks one of the finest
communication gurus in the world mr
michael chad hepner michael welcome
thank you thank you very much now how do
i know this
it's because michael was one of the
people that helped
guide andrew yang to political
comet dumb where
somewhere in the middle of the campaign
we brought in michael and michael taught
me so much
about the fact that communicating is an
as a physical activity
and there were things that uh you do
natively
that you can actually adjust to
a great effect who knew and it took me a
little bit because
i'm the kind of guy and you know and
this is actually very relevant for a lot
of you watching
uh today or listening is that the hope
is that we can actually
provide some valuable insight for you
to actually improve your communication
in an era when
communicating or resume or digitally is
what a lot of us
are doing particularly if you're maybe
in job search mode like this is going to
be a little bit different episode of
yang speaks and that we're going to try
and
give you practical nitty-gritty guidance
as to how to improve your communication
skills uh so michael how the heck did
you get into this line of work
yeah well i come to it from a theatrical
background like many people do
so i trained as a professional actor i
got my mfa at nyu
and i worked in broadway and film and tv
for about five years
and then the last massive economic
crisis we had in 0809
basically ended my acting career that
took two years for that to happen but it
ended right at that point and i'd
already been getting into communications
at that point so
i started a company in 2010 doing this
and then it just took off pretty quick
so i started teaching at columbia
business school in 2014 and then
got roped into politics a little bit in
2016 and then that's just
been the last decade helping people talk
good and stuff
so michael and i met at a dinner party
and then we became friendly uh but that
was not enough for us to say like you
know
let's work with michael so we ended up
going through a whole
uh litany of folks kicking the tires and
then michael rose to the top
so i will say that if you think that
andrew yang had his moments on the trail
um it was in large part from michael's
uh prodding shall we say
so michael you said that you were an
actor on broadway
um you were in a bunch of tv episodes
right like if i imdb
michael hepner you pop up yeah i was a
killer on law order svu one time i meant
spoiling the entire plot of that
particular episode but yes i was a
killer in an episode
yeah exactly but you know what's funny
though is the like the theatrical
training
and the artistic training it's the core
of a lot of it but
what really helped me figure out how to
help people
was just the thing you were referencing
previously is
just how physical communication is
actually and that was one of the big aha
moments that happened in the last 10
years
where i figured out that not just actors
and folks who go through conservatory
training for three years but
anybody really simply by approaching it
in a very kinesthetic very physical way
can unlock what they do natively to your
point what what they do when they're not
even thinking about it
it's so interesting because being a
speaker at the convention i saw it and
then you saw different people
who had to do versions of it at both the
dnc
and rnc and it's very very bizarre
you know because like you're addressing
a camera and you're pretending that
you're talking to
a large group of people and everyone
seems
kind of uh forced uh you know and and i
understand it because i did it
and having done it it's hard
to come across as human through that
kind of medium
yeah it's a challenge i mean it's part
of the reason why i'm happy we're
talking about this because
you obviously had that in a very high
stakes situation the convention
but weirdly everybody's in the same
position now like
everyone all day long is having to do
this and in business or if someone's
looking for a job they're having to do
this
to have pretty high consequence
conversations and to do that in a fluid
way in which somehow
hopefully who they are and what they're
good at and what they like comes across
even through
this medium right here it's kind of the
same thing you had to do at the
convention
yeah go ahead i mean i'm passionate
about this because so many americans are
struggling to find a job right now tens
of millions of americans
and it would be very difficult to put
your best foot forward
from afar and there are a lot of
corporations that i'm sure
are doing interviews over zoom right now
uh everybody everybody's doing it over
zoom right now i mean
zoom or skype or whatever it is yeah
go-to meeting and
yeah all of it it's all like on-camera
training now which is pretty crazy to
think
how much interaction is happening in
that way and the
hard part is to your point about how
we've been looking at how society is
sort of getting
slotted into people who have a lot of
advantages and people who don't
it's crazy the expectation that is put
on people i mean even just the most
basics of do you have a space that you
can actually go to
to be on video and talk to someone
uninterrupted it's it's really
challenging
i agree uh and hopefully you can help
push people in a better direction so if
you're
listening to this at home i know most of
us are like this
i communicate how i communicate if i
have a zoom interview i'm going to push
the zoom on
i'm going to talk to the camera
and then if people like me great if they
don't like me
then screw them and you know like what
kind of phony nonsense are we dealing
with here where now
i have to actually think about how i
talk
to people uh so so
that i think is most people's default uh
shall we say
um but i i want you to think about this
as the same
you would any other high stakes activity
where
if if you have a big track meet or
something you don't just roll out or a
marathon or something you don't roll out
and be like yeah i'll just wing it
this time i mean you train for it you
try and eat right you treat yourself
right i mean there's a little bit this
metaphor is not great because
you don't necessarily go get a massage
before you have a job interview
but you know like just leaving it up to
your native
impulses may or may not be the right way
to put your best foot forward
yeah well the weird thing is it so
people think about like their
presentation or their presence
as being something that's all about them
and so they think like when i'm
comfortable i come across well and when
i'm uncomfortable i don't
and the funny thing is that for almost
everyone
you come across the best when you're
actually trying to communicate something
to someone else i mean
legitimately other focused so as an
example like let's say a friend comes to
you and the friend is in a crisis and
you start talking to the friend
and you hear what's happening to them i
promise you like right away
your eye contact improves right away you
begin to speak
in very technical language if that's
needed or very very colloquial and
casual language
if that's needed right away you slow
down your rate of speech
if the person's having a hard time
digesting what you're sharing you do all
that automatically and you never think
about like my
presentation skills you just do it
because you're using all of yourself to
try to reach the other person
now what happens in this format is that
i mean for
a bunch of reasons one of which is you
have a little floating box of your video
right there that you're staring at part
of the time of like what are my hands
doing what is my face doing
it's very hard not to feel
self-conscious the entire time
and be thinking about my communication
skills but what you want to do is
unlock what people do when they're
actually very focused on the other
person
and the strange thing is right now even
as weird as that camera feels
this is the vehicle that people have to
reach
everybody friends family an employer
anyone this is the vehicle we have
so helping people unlock that idea of
other focus
even when they can't help but be a
little bit self-focused is really
important
oh so it's caring about what the other
person is getting
as opposed to what you are doing at any
moment
in time so do you have uh
principles or things that people can
keep in mind to try to
improve their ability to communicate
digitally right now
yeah yeah i do this relates a little bit
to you so you said you know i got in the
presidential race because
i'm looking around me and there's a lot
of huge problems and i feel like i
should try to fix some of these problems
it's an exaggeration to say i got into
communications training for the same
reason but it's
kind of like that in other words there
is a lot of really terrible coaching out
there that people get
and what i mean by that is not like that
they go take a class somewhere
there's a lot of received ideas about
how you should be better as a
communicator
and it tends to fall into two things one
is something called thought suppression
and number two is tremendously reductive
coaching so
thoughts oppression sounds like this
don't be nervous
andrew just be yourself okay so that's
thought suppression coaching you're
welcome for that by the way that's
great number two is like
when you speak make sure you speak in
the lower third of your voice and make
broad commanding gestures to emphasize
key points
where were these instructions when i
needed them michael i'm kidding
don't be nervous and speak low and just
your big
damn it i could have been president if
you had just clued me in
you know what's frightening it that kind
of feedback happens at the highest
levels too
it absolutely does and it's part of why
you see people
making the same gesture over and over
again or speaking this very reductive
manner all the time to try to emphasize
key points no matter what they're
talking about
so people get this really reductive
coaching and the thought suppression is
even worse actually because the thought
suppression like just as i told you
don't be nervous as soon as i say that
your brain goes right to thought
suppression which is like don't do this
thing your brain's obligated to look at
the thing
because it's looking at that thing now
it's thinking about that thing and how
bad you
are at not doing that thing and of
course people get kind of paralyzed in
that
so my goal is always to try to get them
out of thought suppression
and reductive coaching and try to unlock
what they do really really well
when they are back to that point other
focused as opposed to totally
self-focused
i love it you know when you talked about
like the speak deep
um the person that made me think of was
elizabeth holmes the
founder of theranos who i met once and
and she was like hello i'm elizabeth and
you were like oh
i think it was an affectation to throw
us off the scent that it was all a
billion dollar fraud anyway
um so okay so so those are the things
that
are kind of over simplifications that
are out there that people should not be
taking a heart
all right this podcast is brought to you
by unagi scooters
i have one of these and i ride around in
new york
and i love it it's pretty fast
it's not that heavy which is great i
mean it's well built but
you can fold it and carry it upstairs or
for me i've got a two-floor walk-up
but i can take out my stairs pretty
easily it charges fast it lasts for a
while
i look kind of ridiculous in some ways
but in a good way because i'm
kind of tall and awkward riding this
thing but it's fast it's awesome i
freaking love this thing
cnet actually rates it says the best
all-around electric scooter so it's not
just me saying how awesome it is the
pros actually think this thing's great
too so
unagi scooters has an awesome discounts
for you and you can get yours
at unagi scooters.com so that's u n a g
i scooters dot com and act now with the
discount code yang and get 150
off the yanagi e500 so don't hesitate
this thing was the best decision i made
in kovid because i don't have to ride
public transportation
i don't have to ride on the subway i
don't have to take the main train i can
ride my scooter anywhere
unaugiescooters.com use the discount
code yang
[Applause]
so we have a couple of things that are
out there in the world
that are not great pieces of advice for
folks so
so what's the the good stuff it sounds
like you're trying to discover
who you really are there's like the
self-discovery process to
communicating um at the risk of being
totally dismissive
no that's not actually what i would say
i would change that entirely
i would change that entirely what i
would say is this is that helping people
unlock like who they are really
are is simply a matter of reminding them
how they use themselves when they're at
their most comfortable or their most
least self-conscious i should say so
like if you're asking about principles a
couple things immediately
one you alluded to this which is that
people totally underestimate how
deeply physical spoken communications
are
so people think like if i've done my
homework if i've prepared my powerpoint
slides if i prep for the interview if
i've gone over the questions i might get
asked
i'm gonna do great and it's not true i
mean think about how many like
scientists
or subject matter experts there are who
are phenomenal in terms of what they
know but they can't actually communicate
it
very well at all so the point is that
when you put
words into language this remarkable
coordination happens where
your diaphragm drops down your lungs
fill with air
that air then flows over your vocal
cords they vibrate they actually move in
space they make some sound
the sound amplifies throughout your
whole body and then your mouth and your
tongue and your lips and your throat
your jaw
they all work together to shape that raw
sound into words that can be understood
so it's much much closer to a sport than
it is
any kind of mental exercise it's part of
the reason why we would always warm up
we put so much focus on the campaign of
like getting yourself
physically and vocally primed to
communicate so the biggest principle
that people mess up all the time is they
think it's all about what's up here
and so much of it has to do with what's
happening down here
and you can actually prepare that and
the reason that's so liberating is
because
that you can actually control you can't
control what question you're going to
get from the interviewer you can't
but you can control how you've prepared
yourself physically and vocally
to take that question and hopefully hit
out of the park so
what would those preparation activities
look like for someone pre-job interview
um yeah so that's another big thing to
apply to which is this
people are good at something whoever is
listening is right now you're good at
something you're an expert in something
and oftentimes there's some sort of a
ritual or regimen you go through with
that thing that helps you
do that thing well so for instance if
you're an athlete
warm up physically like an athlete
before you begin speaking if you're a
dancer same thing if a singer
same thing but even if you like to do
something much more
cerebral like board games there are
still principles that can be applied
to speaking that apply one to one from
that sort of discipline
so one thing i often tell people is like
choose something you're already very
expert in
figure out what the principles are of
that and apply it to communication
that's kind of vague but i can get much
more specific if you want yeah please
yeah sure i'm just i'm imagining i'm a
person i'm a
viewer and let's say i'm listening to
this and i have a job interview tomorrow
and so then i'm like okay now thanks to
michael like i'm going to approach this
like a little bit more of a physical
activity
and then instead of cramming notes into
my head right before
the interview i'm going to do this
instead
well what you would do this instead is
you'll get physically and vocally warmed
up
you can do tongue twisters you can do
stretches you can get your body and your
breath
ready to go there's a bunch of stuff we
can share with your viewers and
listeners if you want to in terms of
resources and access and stuff like that
we can get to but
that's the principle of the idea then as
opposed to thinking about everything on
the page
grab a cell phone and talk into it and
give yourself rhetorical questions
if i were to get asked this question
what would i say
and start recording it if you want to if
you want to listen back if you don't
want to even the practice of just saying
this stuff
out loud helps actually get your body
physically ready to go and begins to
take those talking points
from a bunch of stuff in your head and
actually puts it into the real world
by speaking it out loud so one warm up
two yeah yeah go ahead
no no no you you you go ahead you just
yeah warming up actually
yeah warm up actually ah but i'm pumped
warm up
practice actually saying this stuff out
loud and do it so that you're priming
yourself with a question
meaning if i were to put this in the
form of a story it might be
or if i get this question what i might
say is
so you're actually practicing saying
things out loud so you know those tv
characters where before the big
interview they always are
practicing talking into a mirror to like
pump themselves up before they go to the
interview so you're saying that actually
is wise like it's not just like
on on tv that you see characters doing
that that's actually a good idea yeah
well
with a caveat sometimes being in the
mirror makes people a bit more
self-conscious so you may want to have
that visual feedback you may not
but putting sound into words is
absolutely essential
i mean a different way to look at the
same thing is like is your 10 30 a.m
phone call better than your 9 a.m phone
call
and for a lot of people the answer is
yeah yeah
what they've done is they used the
interview that was at 9 00 and 9 15 and
9 30 and 10 a.m
as warm-ups to get to the 10 30. so my
point is
start early and put the warm-up by
yourself early in the day before that
and then actually your body will be
physically and vocally primed
and ready to go to communicate well wow
that makes a world of sense to just
about everyone listening to this
that just try and make every call your
10 30 call so to speak
yeah but by getting physically and
vocally primed
by doing an hour and a half of something
ahead of time so you're not cold
well you know what's cool though you
don't need an hour and a half like
really
five minutes we'll do the trip ten
minutes is even better
and there's time tested warm ups and
tongue twisters and exercises you can do
and of course we'll make that available
to anybody on this
who listens here but you can also just
google stuff but we have a whole series
of
video warm-ups that we give to clients
they can follow along
because it is a little bit different
than a sport in that when you're
speaking
it's all about this channel right here
so your mouth
your lungs your windpipe here your torso
now if you're going to play baseball of
course it's a lot about your wrists and
things like that
communication is a little bit different
that way so there are specialized
warm-ups that you can do that are about
how
you walk and talk and you have some free
resources on your website right which
we'll put in the links
uh yeah yeah
one of the things that i feel
passionately about so we
when this all happened in march when
coronavirus changed the world
temporarily
we took all of our training and we put
it online and
so that's everything from executive
presence to remote communication et
cetera et cetera
and then what we decided to do is take
the remote communication course so
exactly the topic that you and i are
talking about right now
and make it free and open to anybody if
they've lost a job been fired been
furloughed something like that
so this was inspired actually by you and
by ubi
and by some of the ways in which you're
trying to give resources to people
so we thought all people have to do is
just email us and say
i lost my job or i've been fro can i
have access to this course
well because of that we've been pushing
out just a bunch of stuff a bunch of
content
for people and hopefully it helps them
yeah that's what
uh we're hoping happens from this
conversation today all right keep going
so now i'm i'm approaching it like a
physical activity
i'm warming up so i'm not stumbling on
myself
first thing what's next what's next okay
so the next principle is this is that
because
communication is a physical art form it
needs to be
learned physically so i'll often say to
people like
uh there's this virtuous cycle between
content and delivery you might remember
this from
our conversations we've had so content
is what you say and delivery is how you
say it
and everybody around the world can
remember this for the rest of your life
because if you hold up your two hands
like you're
holding binoculars your left hand looks
like a c yeah go for it there you go
left hand looks like a c right hand
looks like the outer half of a d
content is what you say in delivery is
how you say it and the two things link
together
into a virtuous or a vicious cycle into
a heart
into a heart and right there i'm holding
a content and delivery heart for you
right yes
it links together and then people think
that it only goes from content to
delivery
meaning if i know what i'm talking about
i will say good stuff
but what's more profound actually is the
other way because you can actually
practice and control your delivery in a
bunch of different manners so i'll give
you an example of how to do this
we often work with people physically and
this is
i'll grab this right here but there's a
couple i keep these my desk is littered
with these things because it's what i
end up helping people do all day long i
have a stack of lego blocks
i have a whole little stack of post-it
notes here
and if you work with someone who is a
relentless fast talker
let me tell you how not to help them say
hey listen andrew that was great you did
a great job tonight but listen
next time just just talk a little slower
it doesn't help i'm sure you know why
that doesn't help because you're nodding
your head but it doesn't because a
person you've not given them anything
actionable even more so you're not
giving them anything physical or
kinesthetic they can hang on to
so instead we often say to people take a
lego block
say one idea at the end of that idea in
silence
stack this lego block until it clicks in
place with the next one
then pick up another block say the next
id at the end of that idea
stack the lego block again in silence
next idea
lego block next idea lego block you can
do a post-it notes too
they're easier to transport and most
folks have post-it notes but what you're
doing there
is you're forcing a change in terms of
how their physical communication
instrument is working you're giving them
almost a muscle interruption
because people who relentlessly speak
quickly especially in interviews
they feel like i've got to get all the
information out as fast as they can
and they begin to stumble over their
words because of it that's a muscle
memory habit
so in fact they can even practice
forcing themselves to actually
insert a pause share one idea at a time
and the weird cool thing about remote
communication
and not everything about remote
communication is cool but
one of the things that is good is we
actually have this weird little
boundary right here i call this a cloak
of invisibility i'm wiggling my hands
i'm still wiggling them andrew whoa now
i'm wiggling still but they're still
wiggling
so people can actually use kinesthetic
training to try to force them to change
some of their habits wow yeah wow they
can cheat
this is some cheating stuff here michael
i can cheat i'm putting legos together
with my hands and you can't see i'm
kidding
yeah i mean this is actu i will say i do
a lot of zooming which is probably not
shocking to people right now but a lot
of the time your hands are not
uh visible and so i'm doing stuff
like i'll do stuff with my hands too not
the lego thing but like i'll
so i i love it so you can use a physical
activity to kind of adjust yourself
yeah and it sounds wacky it's not it's
actually called embodied
cognition so that's a big fancy
scientific term for it basically means
you're learning something by doing
getting information from your body not
just your brain
because a lot of the habits that people
go into when interviewing are things
that
they're fundamentally not in control of
they get anxious
they stop breathing they stop breathing
their mind gets a bit panicked because
their
cells on a cellular level are telling
your brain
you're drowning because no oxygen is
coming into the system so they feel like
i'm drowning
what that does speed up the heart rate
the heart starts pumping faster big
muscle groups start getting recruited
small muscle groups lock up it's like a
little bunny rabbit in the headlights of
a car
and then in that state what they're
telling themselves is like
say something smart say something smart
say something smart and then inevitably
they don't and then they say like oh
you're such an idiot why didn't you say
a smart thing
so that i said that to myself an awful
lot
no i'm kidding
[Laughter]
what did you say i mean i don't know i
mean i've definitely been there
uh many times in my life um i'd actually
think
say one of the biggest things about
running for president and adapting
was not doing that because i think my
natural tendency earlier in life
was to monday
morning quarterback myself or whatnot be
like oh we should have done this should
have done
that but when you were in campaign mode
you essentially
needed to just go next thing next thing
uh you know and if you beat yourself up
over something
um you know you had another shot at it
well
an hour later or whatever it was yeah
and which is not the same in job
interview world because it's not like
you have a job interview every hour but
uh so i'm just i was just sharing like
one of the
things that i had to get better at was
essentially
not beating myself up but it is
it's very related actually i mean in a
way this drill i'm talking about right
now it's exact same thing
which is you're in the middle of some
thought you're in an interview
you can feel it's going badly i'm saying
dumb stuff this is not going well i'm on
a tangent oh
crap where am i going but building that
muscle memory discipline
you force yourself to stop finish that
thought
and you know what i'm going to start
afresh on this next thought
because what tends to happen is people
hit the gas pedal and things go south
and then
the whole vicious cycle kicks in so it's
actually the same thing but just on a
almost a sentence by sentence or thought
by thought basis as opposed to an entire
media event when you're on the campaign
trail
[Applause]
[Music]
this episode of yank speaks is brought
to you by our friends at expressvpn so i
didn't know anything about
vpn before i connected with expressvpn
and this podcast um and i got to try it
out for free
like you can with our with our code and
it's
it's amazing it's literally seamless to
what you're normally doing in terms of
browsing the internet but you know that
you're secure you know that people don't
they're not taking your cookies now
taking your info they have no idea where
you're coming from which is great
the other day i watched um that movie
inside man
with denzel washington clive owen
and jody foster forgot shoes in that
movie and the movie was amazing
total badass movie and i watched it on
vpn
um and i couldn't tell the difference
between it didn't slow down my
connection in
any sort of capacity um so expressvpn
keeps all of your information secure by
encrypting 100 of your data
with the most powerful encryption
available and you guys got to check it
out so
protect your online activity today with
the vpn rated number one by cnet
and wired visit our exclusive link
expressvpn.com
yang and you can get an extra three
months free on a one-year package that's
s s e-x-p-r-e-s-s dot com slash yang
expressvpn.com learn more
so the third thing is to have some kind
of physical cues to adjust your behavior
you've just described the fast talking
nervous
type are there other examples of
physical activities if i've got a
different issue
yeah for sure for sure i'll give you a
bunch i'll give you one that
the other ones i'll talk about i ones
i've invented or developed working with
professionals but this one is actually
something that goes back to
ancient greece here i'm gonna move back
in space andrew watch this whoa
i'm moving back in the room whoa
so i keep this whole like little wall of
nice cities for clients partly because
moving in space actually wakes people
back up
so part of my job when you're on zoom
all day is to visually stimulate people
in different ways
but there's also a whole wall of
kinesthetic tools i use back there to
help people speak better
it's very montessori what'd you say this
is very montessori
very modest i guess i guess you should
do that during an interview being like
i'm now
going to change levels with you just to
wake you up interview or maybe it would
be good i don't know or maybe it would
seem weird
why do you think people move across a
stage in large talks when they're trying
to anchor points for
the audience point number one happens
here point number two here point number
three here
oh i agree with it would be effective
but uh obviously the
new decorum is to just sit ramrod
straight and stare at your
camera the whole time if you if you did
this rocket back and forth thing it
might wake you up but it'd be like why
is the person rocking back and forth
no being like be like oh oh wait wait
i'm gonna do my rain man impression
i would do a very nice job i would do a
very nice job
that's not a very very good one anyway
well
i can get away with a lot more than
maybe someone who's interviewing for a
job because my entire
purpose is to help people get better and
to keep them awake and engaged while i
do that
so you're right i would not recommend
doing that over and over on a job
interview bad idea
bad idea anyway so it did yeah go ahead
no it did certainly work for you though
all right continue
sorry you got the cork so i got this
cork it's a wine cork you can slice it
into slivers this is the
the tool that's very old this idea this
principle goes all the way back to
ancient greece
an order named demosthenes who would
practice speaking with an impediment
in his mouth and i learned this from the
head of voice and speech at the royal
shakespeare company in london a guy
named andrew wade
when i studied with him at the guthrie
theater in minnesota anyway
that's the pedigree of it but all you do
is talk with the impediment in between
your teeth like that
now i have updated this for coronavirus
times
which people don't want to put stuff in
their mouth or on their face
which makes sense bad ideas so instead
i've been coaching folks to use
this because they do put this in their
mouth two times a day
so for the folks who get on zoom calls
and they begin to get all mealy mouthed
and they stumble over their words and as
they do that they feel bad about what
they're saying so they talk even faster
and they close their mouth more and as
they close their mouth more the words
come out even worse they begin to
stumble even more
as opposed to critiquing yourself
negatively about that and falling
all back in that thought suppression
trap instead
i just have to practice speaking with a
toothbrush between their teeth
two times a day in the morning spit up a
toothpaste
practice with a toothbrush for 60
seconds and in the evening the same
thing because what you're doing
just like a swimmer who puts on a couple
extra swimsuits in the practice pool
so they increase the drag and they're
faster in the actual meat what you're
doing is you're making your muscles jobs
harder so these muscles they're not used
to communicating in a really dynamic
really dexterous really forceful way
and you're building stronger muscles by
doing that so that's
one that's about enunciation addiction
and clarity
that's like putting weights on when
you're walking or whatnot
wow that's exactly restricting your
communication muscles um
fascinating continue there's one for
what i call linguistic precision
and all that means is are you saying
what you want to be saying or not
so like lots and lots of people again
back to thought suppression they get off
the stage someone says that was great
but listen
you know some staffer comes up with a
clipboard they say but next time just
say a couple fewer ums it looked like
you were kind of stammering on that one
answer so
just try not to say um just pause
instead
so that sounds like good feedback right
because you've been given an actionable
thing
pause instead of saying um okay fine
does it work
no because all the person's doing is
thinking about the um which by the way
is not actually that big of a deal
people are weirdly quite forgiving of
filler language it exists on a bit of a
hockey stick curve so
people don't really notice it until they
do and then once they do it becomes more
and more problematic but
it's actually pretty forgiving so the
bigger problem though is that people get
focused on it themselves
so what they can actually play around
with is a drill i've created called
finger walking and
all people have to do is walk their
fingers
across their desk or table like so
forcing themselves to choose
each and every single word that they
share
once they've reached the end of one
thought they can move their hand back to
the front of the desk or so
but not until they've completed that
idea
so the point here is that filler
language is not a problem it's a symptom
it's a symptom of you not being in as
much charge of what you're saying as you
could be
and the problem is not the um the
problem is you're not being as precise
as you could be with all the other words
but just thinking that is not enough the
activity of
actually using embodied cognition to
commit to each and every single word
helps people focus in a physical way on
the language they're choosing as opposed
to the little filler words they're
trying
to avoid so that's something focused on
linguistic precision
saying smart stuff saying it in a very
accurate and precise way
this is something you could do in the
zoom era because you could do the
walking with your fingers choosing every
single word deliberately
and just do it on your leg without
anyone seeing
yeah and then people will say like you
can't do that in real life and i'm like
yeah you can
yeah you can you can do that a few
minutes a day and you're going to build
muscle memory and you know what it'll be
faster
than the last 10 years when you've been
telling yourself like stop saying um
when i get nervous stop saying um stop
saying um stop saying up
that didn't work for 10 years so don't
do that anymore
do this instead a little bit and build
some muscle memory
so those are a couple examples of this
approach of kinesthetic learning and
embodied cognition to build on the
delivery side of things
positive communication habits that help
unlock both smart stuff and smart stuff
delivered well
wow i love the mind body connection
aspect because
we all need that i believe and you're
right that everyone's been told to do
something and then you can't actually
put that advice into into practice very
quickly
yeah you know that's like i think a bit
of an unexplored frontier with this
whole thing
which is there's this really powerful
thing that unlocks when you get people
communicating better is they feel better
and it's not just because they feel
better because they said smart stuff
i've been thinking about this a lot
because i've been i wrote a piece for
thrive global ariana huffington's
organization just about helpfulness and
i'm considering examining this more and
more and more
which is when you're communicating well
in order to do that you actually have to
stand
up a little bit more to have room for
your diaphragm to drop down and your
lungs to fill with air
and you actually have to open your mouth
a bit more for the sound to come out
and you actually have to use your body
in a more dynamic way so on a really
granular level
you're actually using yourself more like
an athlete and it begins to unlock
actually feeling better you have to
breathe more that oxygen actually helps
your life so people are so focused right
now
on how sitting is bad and it is sitting
as much as we do for
you know remote existence right now it's
bad is that why you're standing is that
something you'd recommend for folks
yeah well two things so i have a stool
too that i can sit on at times because
it's not realistic to think that you can
stand for eight hours a day
you know and you want to be able to go
back and forth but yeah people should
stand
for a significant amount of time during
the day they should if they can
so if someone has let's call it a
20-minute job interview sitting or
standing
hmm i would say standing well that's a
very very concrete piece of
advice and i have to say that i'm
imagining you being interviewed
and it seems like you would be more
effective standing because you seem more
comfortable
and energetic i know when i was a
candidate
if i had a choice between sitting or
standing i always stood because you were
just more energetic
well you tell me i mean i agree with you
but for you why did you why'd you make
that choice
certainly as a candidate i would because
you would project more you would walk
around more you would keep people's
attention better
you would yourself be more energized
is more active the other thing is a
candidate too for me
part of my entire jam was being uh
relatively young no offense to anyone
but you know
relatively dynamic and so so
any chance i had to uh
exude some more energy i would take it
yeah well you're not alone in that most
people are better
i mean chairs are not good for us we're
not designed to sit by the way we're
designed to squat
uh chairs are sort of this you know
weird modern anomaly
and it's very hard to communicate well
when you're all smushed down like that
in your lower back
and it's actually quite hard to have
really good long released posture when
you're seated so
in general most people can communicate
better when standing not all the time
but in general so it's a pretty easy fix
for most people especially you can just
put the computer the desktop
or the laptop on top of a dresser or
something like that
[Music]
all right we've got an interesting
sponsor for this episode we're sponsored
by the jordan harbinger show
which is a podcast you all really should
be listening to and
i know that every day someone tells you
you have to try out this podcast
and you're like yeah that sounds great
um but then you never do it so i need
you to not do that and actually listen
to this show because it's pretty great
so apple named it one of its best in
2018 and
yang jokes of this podcast has homework
which it kind of does but it's meant to
be educational in a really really
powerful interesting exciting way so
each episode's like conversation with
different fascinating guests
and when i say there's something for
everyone here i mean that so one episode
jordan talks to a hostage negotiator
from the fbi who offers technique
techniques on how to get people to like
you and trust you and another episode
talks about a cinematographer
who discovered a lost city in the jungle
and made one of the
most important like archaeological finds
of the century
so the range is crazy they're doing a
piece on a guy who is undercover in the
mob
right now there's another piece on how
not to get scammed so i've listened to
that to help my grandmother
and myself because i'm kind of prone to
that crap anyway um
it's a fascinating show i like it
because it's a good way to learn
um in an interactive way and and kind of
better yourself so
check out the jordan harbinger show
that's h-a-r-b
as in boy i n as in nancy g e r
that's on apple podcast spotify wherever
you listen
you guys will like this so jordan
harbinger
um or the jordan harbinger show you can
find it anywhere you find podcasts
tune in
[Applause]
so you described that you have your own
space and it's
obviously i mean in your case you're
doing this all day long how do you
create a good first impression digitally
in terms of having a backdrop that seems
professional without going overboard
sure well people have probably at this
point heard a bunch of the basic stuff
you want a light source from the front
so your face can be seen
you want a present background so you
have a bit of a depth of field mine is
actually
probably busier than you want for an
interview or things like that
i do it again because i'm trying to keep
folks awake
and engaged and then i can reference
things like
fox and socks if i want them to do
tongue twist or something you know what
has changed my life
uh i don't know if you have one of these
i'll see if i can show everybody
um it's one of these circle lights
uh-huh uh
that like those things yeah like i'll
show you all what it looks like i mean
you can looks like a ufo now
um but right i like this thing has
definitely changed everything for me in
terms of zooming
because you stick it there and then
there's always a light on your face
uh i think it might have cost i don't
know
30 bucks 40 bucks yeah this
this is nine this is i think 19 and it's
for a laptop you just put it
right there on the you know the cameras
right there from the lid of the
clamshell of the laptop
yeah now that thing is hella cool like
tell like what is that thing is there a
brand on that i love it yours is cooler
than mine
now yours is cool no way andrew yours is
cooler than mine
uh i don't know what the brand is but
these are you know get generic versions
of these
this is a smaller one so it fits for a
laptop if i have a
laptop right here but you know you get
the idea you just place it
right there on the lid of the laptop
like so
like so yeah around the camera and
that way you have that light source that
you're talking about even if you're just
on a laptop computer
so simple thing like that yeah go ahead
no so
so lighting from the front yeah some
depth
uh behind you not too busy
uh preferably standing yep and then you
want to have the camera roughly at eye
level which you're doing a great job of
by the way right now
now that sounds like a few things to
remember right you're like huh three
things okay what should i do exactly
it's really simple just think of it this
way if you were setting a friend up
for a good photo when you're traveling
you would do these same things you would
not put the sun like right behind their
head
you would not make the background the
least attractive part of the scenery
and you would also not shoot them from
an unflattering angle like
up their nose or something like that so
just do the same exact three principles
when you're setting yourself up visually
for success right that's
enormously helpful so so far we have uh
a few things that i think
anyone can implement uh number one is
that this is a physical activity
uh so warming up is helpful um
if you have an issue that you're working
with
try and integrate some kind of physical
tool uh to
develop in the right direction don't
just think oh don't do this because the
negative thoughts don't work
set up your physical environment in a
way that's going to present you
positively so that's front lighting some
depth
eye level not too busy i feel like
already we're going to improve a lot of
people's situations
because i i know a lot of people um
do not do any of the things that you and
i are describing
where and this is again this is not a
knock on anyone because i'm wired this
way too it's like oh i've got a job
interview
all right like you know let's just set
the laptop up and like do the thing and
then uh
and and you think well like what kind of
jerk cares about
my lighting quality or my background
but we're in a world where people just
take cues from whatever they can yeah
and so if there's a way for them to
judge you harshly they'll probably take
it because that's just the way the world
is
yeah but you're right man it's it's
deeper than that too if like this is now
sort of our resume
believe it or not so people do evaluate
people
in aesthetic ways that's becoming more
true too i mean when this first happened
i think we were in this tremendous
moment of cultural empathy
and that almost like the crappier that
your setup was the more people
empathize with it and related with it
but we're now going on like month five
and six and employers are going to begin
to have a real impression
of your professionalism based on how you
can comport yourself via video
so it is important to keep these things
in mind it really is
and also like if you can't see my face
you actually have a much more difficult
time trusting me i mean i was i listened
to your podcast so
you and rutger talked about this right
that humans have the most expressive
faces of any animals in the animal
kingdom and so part of why it's so
important so that the employer can see
your face so the person can see your
face is not to like
look good on camera but actually all of
our cues
we pick up on each other about is this
person someone i trust
can i get a sense of what they're
actually telling me in an authentic way
part of it is the visual stimuli we
receive from their faces so it's not
just like a
have a nice window dressing it's
actually core to the interaction you're
going to have
with the employer whoever it might be
it's true we have to learn to trust
people remotely
and so you're going to take whatever
cues you can
and we're still mammals we're still just
biological creatures so you know
we'll take some of the same cues that
we've been taking for centuries
yeah yeah i'll give you another simple
thing that people can adopt right away
that helps that
which is i call this narrating and what
i mean by that is that you can't tell
what i'm looking at right
now it seems like i'm looking at you
well i put your video box as close to
the camera as i can so i actually
am looking at you but if you have to
look away for whatever reason which
people do all the time right
they're going to look over here to do
something you can actually narrate for
people what you're doing
i'm just going to pull up the
description of the thing that you sent
to me right now ah
so you actually named for them the
activity of what you're doing and it's a
very subtle way
to help build trust so that they feel as
though you're 100
present with them because they can't
tell of course so you can simply do that
narrating what you're doing a different
one if you want a different one for
people is it
oftentimes the strongest thing you can
do when things go wrong because they
will
they're going to go wrong it's not like
an if it's a win the strongest thing you
can do is actually be transparent
in some way and so because people get
interrupted there's dogs there's pets
there's tech challenges
people can actually embrace that and
especially if you're talking about
hiring someone that is going to
demonstrate a level of
in the moment resiliency in the moment
calm spontaneity that is actually a good
thing so when mistakes happen people can
actually just be transparent about it
though i was trying to make a marco
rubio joke
like that or whatever it is but you know
what's funny though so just now you take
a drink of water
that's transparent right
you trying to hide the fact that you're
taking a drink of water
not so transparent so that's a perfect
example of what we're talking about
certainly if you do get interrupted
during an interview as long as you
seem confident and have the right spirit
then people will
i think completely accepted like i've
had my kids run in
uh all sorts of times and then sometimes
people like oh that's cute i mean if it
happened all the time then you know
and there was a job context maybe not as
cute anymore
but certainly if you have like a good
attitude uh then
people will let that stuff go nine times
out of ten
yeah i teach i teach three apps for this
it's a little bit like
you know schticky because it's
alliterative but people remember stuff
because it's literature so it helps
people out
so we teach the idea of fake it or
feature it or fix it
and so fake it means like if the kid
runs in but
no one knows if the kid's like right
here like hi daddy
they're just doing that thing you don't
have to say like hey michael my kid's
standing right here you can just fake it
great
but if the kid steals the attention of
the whole thing you can either feature
it or
fix it and feature it means just what
you did like hey my kid's here say hello
we should talk about what to do with
interruptions i'm on zoom let's do that
for a second
or you just fix it there's my kids say
hello all right i'll be back later
you just handle it so if those f's are
helpful for people that's what you can
think of in a pretty structured manner
i'll fake it or feature it or fix it
yeah we've all had those zoom
interruptions so what are the best
practices
that's that's really it that's what i
recommend fake it or future it or fix
it all right well done look at that
[Music]
alright guys i am so excited to share
with you a brand new limited documentary
podcast that is sponsoring yank speaks
and this podcast series is called it was
said
and we highly recommend it so the series
will move you it's
inspirational for sure and it's uh i'm
going to call it a muslis in in covid so
what it is it's a 10 episode documentary
podcast
it's a limited series and explores and
brings to life 10 of the most historic
speeches in american history um and
what's cool about it
is that it was said was written and
narrated by pulitzer prize-winning and
best-selling author
historian this guy named john meacham
and then is created by the peabody
nominated c13 original studios these
guys know what they're doing and they're
partnering with history
so it's freaking fascinating they cover
some of the most
timeless and impactful speeches in
american history so you're gonna have
people
on this it was said podcasts like martin
luther king jr and ronald reagan and jfk
and john lewis and edward murrow and
barbara jordan and more and puts you in
these moments in time
that are still relevant frankly and
important today so
meacham the host offers this kind of
expert insights and analysis
into their origins of the speech and so
the orator and the context and the times
they were given
and frankly why they still matter today
and why it's important we never forget
them so each episode this documentary
will bring together some of the top
historians and authors and journalists
to give more context to each speech
and frankly the inspiration behind it in
explaining
why that was the case so it was said is
now available for you to subscribe and
listen for free
on apple podcast spotifyradio.com and
wherever
you listen to podcasts so check it out
it was said for you history buffs or
just
curious people like me or andrew that
find this stuff fascinating
tune in
[Applause]
so i feel like people will be on their
way based upon
these principles alone um but i feel
like we're like one less than five right
now and i think we started
like we're looking for the the pinky
[Laughter]
the thinking figure on the whole thing
yeah totally well
what i would actually say is that i want
to give folks one more
tool in terms of a kinesthetic approach
to change something because it can be
very valuable and i think
you might actually have something to
share about it because of
what it helps people do and then i will
give a fifth principle about things
so if you are an athlete or if you like
any kind of and actually if you're not
even an athlete
if you relate to something about
physical engagement
get a wiffle ball or a cushball or a
little racquetball or any kind of a ball
to help you practice one simple thing
which is taking your time
before answering questions so part of
the challenge with the whole
interviewing thing is you get the
question and right away
you have this where did you see yourself
in 10 years michael
that's my joke goes by exactly yeah
requested
where do you see yourself in 10 years i
don't know if people still ask that [ __ ]
i don't know i think they ask
problem-solving questions primarily now
like critical thinking questions and
things like that
probably i don't know i haven't
interviewed in a little while but anyway
point being you're right in the 10 years
so the principle here would be you've
got to train yourself to actually take
the time you need so you can respond and
share a smart
question or a smart response to the
question i should say
so i often have people keep like a
wiffle ball or something like that on
the desk
and actually when they get a question
asked of them
roll the ball forward and let it roll
back to them
and then answer the question now do that
on low consequence calls i mean like
you're just chit chatting with your
friends about stuff but you're building
the discipline of tolerating the
thinking time it takes
to come up with something that you want
to share i even recommend that people do
that
even when they don't need it so you
might get the question in the interview
if like you know
tell me about your experience in your
last job and you actually know
everything you want to say but simply by
giving yourself
some more latitude some more thinking
time before you begin
what you do is you're giving yourself
that margin of safety for when you get
the question that you really
don't know what to say because you will
have built already a track record of
taking your time
as you move through these answers so
that's a little way people can
internalize
that habit of pausing before you speak
one thing i can say with authority is
that whatever time frame you think
you're pausing
it's actually much much shorter than
that i mean so
it might seem to you like you like
you're
pausing for several seconds but it's
probably
significantly less than that it's just
when you're
in that mode of answering a question
even a second
seems like an eternity so you actually
can just let that moment
breathe and just seem like you're
reflecting they've measured this by the
way i mean speakers in high consequence
situations
they can be off by up to 10x of what
they're
you know i keep a sticky on my computer
here to show clients
which is this equation right there do
you see that equation yeah
p is not r yeah any guesses on the
the uh words there perception's not
reality it's mine there you go
yeah perception is not reality and
speakers oftentimes in high consequence
situations they'll be off by up to 10x
so they think a pause is 10 seconds and
it was one second
and you know technology can help in this
actually so
like if you're going to be interviewing
record yourself talking
look back and then actually the little
sound wave thing on the voice
voice memos app will show you notice how
long your pause is
you're right i promise you it's probably
at least three times shorter than you
think it is
probably i got used to this on the trail
where you can pause to reflect and you
realize
that it's only a second and it's
completely natural sounding and whatnot
and no no one thinks you're just sitting
there stress trumping your
chin whiskers thinking about it yeah
but see that goes back to that initial
principle i'm talking about of being
other focused
so like your friend comes to you your
friend's in a crisis they ask you what
to do
you wouldn't feel some sort of
artificial countdown clock of
i better start talking because otherwise
i won't look like i know what i'm
talking about
you would just sit there for a moment
take it and then begin to share
your thoughts as precisely and as
helpfully as you could
because in that moment you're thinking
about one thing which is
what should i say to this person right
now to help this person and that's where
that pause would come from a deeply
organic place
pausing comes from two things two things
alone one
you need some time to think about what
you want to say next
or two you want to give the person
you're talking to time to digest
what you just said so it's not as though
it's too short or too long it is about
you actually tolerating the time it
takes to figure out what you want to say
next
and that simple ball drill is a good way
to make it again
very kinesthetic so people actually
force themselves to do it
because if they try to maintain a pause
like that they're not going to do it
they're going to think they paused for
four seconds and it would have been
half of a second yes half of a second
uh high stakes situations interviewer
camera in your face etc i remember
i remember high stakes situations
all right so that is the fourth and it
sounds like now we're arriving at the
pinky
we are arriving at the pinky yeah so the
pinky is more of a global idea
and the pinky is this i really suggest
for people to try to embrace a growth
mindset about communication it might
sound cliche
it's not so for those of you who might
be wondering what a growth mindset
is carol dweck stanford professor was
one of the first ones to popularize this
idea
just means that you believe you can't
improve in something as opposed to like
there's a fixed state
now the reason i think this is worth
saying on this particular podcast is
because a lot of folks who
don't have a job right now there are
some fixed mindset ideas
about their ability to interview and
that fixed mindset sounds something like
this i'm bad at interviewing or i'm bad
at that first conversation
or if i'm talking to someone who is this
type of person i'm bad with those types
of people
it's a solid state it's not like i'm bad
currently or i haven't learned how to do
this yet
it's a solid state and that's not true
so for instance you can learn how to
pause
you can learn how to enunciate better
you can learn how to be more precise
with your language they are skills just
like a sport
or a musical instrument that one can
practice and the reason that's so
important
is because it puts some power back into
the person's hands
it's a skill you can improve and as you
do so you'll reap the rewards of doing
that i don't mean a job necessarily but
even just a sense of command of
wow i actually am in command of some of
these things
so one of the small things oh go ahead
yeah as a parent we know growth mindset
is the key to
life really right you know if if your
kids like oh i'm bad at that being like
well
you know you can get better because you
can get better just about anything if
you decide to put some time and energy
into it
yeah and as a parent like what is
humbling every damn day and i'm sure you
relate to this
is that like i have these almost
arbitrary categories of what i have a
growth mindset about and what i have a
fixed mindset about and it's just
absurd actually as i hear stuff coming
out of my mouth
and i'm thinking like i don't tell my
kid that right but yet i do so like i'm
bad at technology would be one or
i can't cook would be another one and
all day long i hear myself sometimes
being an awesome dad and demonstrating a
growth mindset i know since i'm modeling
that they will do it too hopefully right
fingers crossed
and i also hear myself saying like these
tremendously
boring frankly fixed mindset things
about all these other stuff so
it's a good reminder you can apply it to
anything but you can definitely apply to
communicating
one thing that michael can say with
absolute authority is that he's seen
people improve
in their ability to communicate every
single day because he's literally
helped them do so and he does it
professionally he's helped at this point
hundreds even thousands of
people communicate their ideas more
effectively
thank you yeah that's that's true that's
how i spend my time
i wouldn't believe in this idea of
growth mindset if i didn't see it all
the time
and i mean i often say that like the
people i work the bravest people i see
are oftentimes the people i'm coaching
because it's a really brave thing to
to look at the things you don't do well
and then try to improve and get better
at that and have that growth mindset
it takes bravery and speaking of bravery
oh yeah go ahead
well i just want to say i i think this
growth mindset is core to a lot of the
things that
we try and stand for you know humanity
forward and the yang gang and everything
else is that
we think that there's so much human
potential that is going
missed and untapped in large part
because
we haven't invested in folks
appropriately and we're all subject to
this
market mindset that is kind of crushing
our potential it's like well like you
you you should be this and you should be
that don't study art like that's a dumb
way to
try and make a living instead we're
gonna try and
drive you toward these other things the
market likes uh whereas the the growth
mindset
can unleash so much in terms of
creativity entrepreneurship
uh and just humanity really human
potential
well that was a lot of what you and
rucker were talking about too that like
our view of the how humans are wired
in terms of our policy it's so just
painfully reductive
depressing frankly like you're always
going to cheat the system
because you just are wired that way and
you reduce this little idea right here
and you're right i mean we should have a
gross growth mindset as a society and i
don't think we do right now i think it's
this
sheer panic white knuckling kind of
approach where
we're taking to civic and public policy
i think your story too is really uh
incredible where you're the artist
thespian
creative performer that then becomes
the entrepreneur business person guru
development executive and now you've
given rise to this
awesome business that employs tons of
people that are going around
helping with people into shape in terms
of this discipline which we all clearly
need i mean
like who the heck rolls out of bed and
is this ace communicator literally none
of us
so if you want to try to develop
particularly in a time when you need to
be able to project yourself
digitally in order to gain a foothold in
the economy in many contexts
um but i think your story really
embodies the the
growth mindset we're talking about well
thank you
you know it's funny when you said that
about liberal arts i actually i have a
near and near spot for a liberal arts
because
i was a history and philosophy major in
undergraduate i
then went into theater and acting for a
bunch of years and then you're right i
embraced entrepreneurialism and as
your story actually shows it's like a
rough go of it at first my goodness
but then it's really rewarding and
really interesting but i would have done
all that crazy weird sort of
ping-ponging career trajectory
if i hadn't had an education that really
did
invite a growth mindset it did invite
like try this thing experiment with this
see what you think of that
it's important and i believe in it yeah
the fact that liberal arts is getting
decimated so much because everyone's
castigating it it's like oh what can you
do with that
well i mean that wasn't the purpose of
the education
uh in the first place when if you look
at why universities were
founded they were founded to educate us
as moral citizens and a lot of them were
based upon
uh how to educate the clergy at that
time so no one was thinking like oh we
gotta make sure this person
has a j.o.b that pays xyz at the end of
it i mean
like that wasn't that wasn't how these
universities were founded
and now the fact that everyone is
yelling about all like this liberal arts
stuff is useless it's like well actually
that kind of that was sort of the point
of this whole
uncertain point in their existence which
extended for decades and losing that
we're going to lose something really
fundamental well your whole argument too
like it points out the absurdity of the
critique
because the time periods in which a
given job is in vogue it's getting
shorter and shorter and shorter
so you can go into college now and four
years later like the career that you had
gotten your thing in
your diploma in might be gone so like
what the heck are we training our people
for if we're saying
these are going to be the jobs of the
future so you should go to college
to be prepared for those jobs
i mean it seems a little bit crazy to me
really we do need to train people how to
think and how to be inventive because
we're going to all have to
be really inventive to figure out how
the heck we navigate the next
years and decades we're also going to
have to do
what what you're training us to do
better which is communicate more
effectively so if someone
wants to go to this uh website of yours
and they've lost their job and they need
to access
uh some kind of remote training uh what
are the resources available to them you
can just say who you like you know
like where they go yeah it's really
simple a couple of things
gktraining.com is the website that's
simple but you can just email us
at info gktraining.com
that's g is in gosh k is in kite
gktraining.com and all you have to
say is i lost my job i've been
furloughed i want to get access to the
program
that's it no questions asked and we'll
give you access to the program
we also have an app that's totally free
people can download that that's a useful
tool it's called
question roulette and it's great for
interviews it has a category
that is just on interviewing skills it
has like 25 common interview questions
in it
you can choose a question and you record
yourself answering the question it
transcribes it gives you metrics how
fast it talks
how much filler you had stuff like that
also how long you spoke for
and then has two settings one is called
rapid fire one is roulette
and the rapid fire is my favorite
because it counts it down and gives you
a random question so to your point it's
like
andrew what will you be doing in 10
years
and you're going to talk and then you
see what the heck comes out of your
mouth
in 10 years i will be president of the
united states
[Laughter]
uh yeah but that's totally free too so
available
apple and android question roulette and
if you want access to the remote
communications program
info gktraining.com well you
are a force for progress and humanity
appreciate the heck out of you and uh
enjoyed spending time with you on the
trail i mean you and i have some
memories that will last a lifetime and
we are just getting started thank you so
much for doing yang speaks
gktraining.com
question roulette let's become better
communicators that we can
have the kind of impact we want to see
in the world
that's my pleasure to job for those of
us who
are looking for that yeah it does that
absolutely does
thank you andrew my pleasure thank you
for listening in i hope you enjoyed this
conversation
if you did please do subscribe to yang
speaks and click on notifications so we
can let you know
every time we have a new episode
[Music]